Let's look at these numbers again for a second. Remember that,looking for
patterns and making educated guesses about what's going on. And then, figuring
out if those guesses are right or wrong is really what math is all about. So,
why do we have 1 plus x here? And why do we have 2 plus x here? Let's look at a
new log for a second. Log base 10 of 3, and I'm going to tell you right now,
this is about equal to 0.47712. Just to make it perfectly clear that this is
rounded, I'm going to change this to an about equal sign. Now, using what log
base 10 of 3 is about equal to, what do you think we can get for log base 10 of
30 and log base 10 of 300? First, using the idea that you came up with before,
I'd like you to make a guess about what each of these is equal to. Then use a
calculator to get the actual answer, and round to 5 decimal places. You won't
be graded on your guesses so just try it out. Then I'd like you to also
consider what log this 10 of 3000 is. And then lastly how about log based 10 of
3 million? Just so you know this is equal to log base 10 of 3 times 10 to the 6
. So make your guesses and then check them with a calculator.